over under over under I'll bet you a
boba tea 15. does that feel right to set
it okay I take the under on that you
take it under on 15 yeah
well well to in your favor in the
Democratic primary that I was in uh the
number was like 22
23.23 is going to go more but the
Republicans are a little there's Trump
and DeSantis in there they're better
about falling in line but who knows
we'll find out it's probably a better at
like 12 but no I think you're I don't
know let's try 15. see what happens
thank you
foreign
[Music]
happy New Year everybody it's me and
Zach ringing in 2023. it's good to be
back I think I don't know if I'll be on
once a month but this Cadence isn't bad
every once in a while come pop my face
on like special occasions special
occasions as elections New Year's Eve
elections yeah a brand new year the best
year yet will it be the best year Zach
and I are going to chew over some
predictions for the New Year in
particular we're going to talk about
the 2024 presidential race I know I know
you're like oh [ __ ] how can we be
talking about the 2024 presidential race
when 2023 is just beginning but the fact
is most of what you think of as the 2024
race will probably happen in 2023
you know like the parties are going to
be con uh settling on nominees not not
entirely but maybe entirely so that's
what we're going to talk about everybody
needs this is the most important thing
everyone needs to know that this year
the Backstreet Boys have dropped a
Christmas album you're welcome forward
listeners uh I haven't reserved I've
only listened to two songs I've just
discovered this I'm sharing with the
world but uh they're not bad so far I'll
let you know I'll let you know so Zach
2023 is now two days old uh what do you
predict for the year ahead I will get us
started I think there's going to be a
recession in 2023 induced by the the fed
and tightening and higher interest rates
and everything else uh magnitude of
recession dunno
um but I think there is at a minimum a
mild recession there are a lot of
businesses uh I know that are cutting
back there are a lot of businesses that
are cutting back publicly
uh you put it all together and I think
that we experience uh like a non-trivial
contraction certainly a technical
recession in 2023 so plan accordingly
everybody
yeah I think that's it's not a certainty
but I think that's going to happen it's
probably not going to be as bad as we
think given that everyone's like
it's gonna be bad it's going to be bad
it's going to be bad it's gonna be bad
um but uh that seems to be happened my
question actually is going to be if you
think it's a recession or a depression
like there are certain
high profile figures that have
given us catastrophic warnings Jeff
Bezos being one there's been a number
um now a lot of them are just kind of
complaining about interest rates being
too high
um but I don't know I don't know if you
think I don't have thoughts on how you
said you don't know the magnitude you
probably have some thoughts you think of
you think it's going to be more on the
like yeah that wasn't so bad or oh boy
we underestimated that I I think it is
likely to be uh
non-trivial uh shall we say
um no there there are a lot of uh
excesses uh still I was talking to a guy
who runs frankly a large investment
business where he
um
makes bets on stocks and whatnot and he
says that because interest rates have
been so low for so long essentially a
let's call it a decade of really low
rates uh that there are entire business
models that are essentially predicated
on having access to money at near zero
and then being able to generate returns
at a certain level and those businesses
no longer make sense when uh interest
rates are as high as they are and so
have those businesses all just going out
of business no are they going to go out
of business at some point yes
so so he said they're like entire
segments of the market that fall into
that category I think I think you're
right I don't
um
nervous for it
um I'm nervous for the millions of
Americans that it'll hit really really
hard
um it's there are companies cutting back
you know we've had a lot we've had a
we've had a good run you know it's time
to die like like big picture people talk
about uh greed versus fear or risk on
versus risk off uh IC 2023 is like a
building year uh where I I would not be
uh super aggressive that that like that
that's just you know it's just uh Andrew
Yang's feeling on on the economic uh
headwinds and Tailwinds okay uh
what do you have for Zach I'll start my
first one
um we're going to see a war play out in
media that Elon Musk has now started
um it's gonna be between our
establishment versus mainstream
journalists and now that has been
happening obviously it was evident when
we were running but it's going to Peak
this year
um you're going to see
I think broadcast and mainstream media
are going to decline rapidly in their
numbers and I think you're going to see
bigger Outlets start to grow faster and
I think I think Twitter accelerates that
or just like divides that I think it
becomes one of the issues that divides
this country uh Elon Musk himself as the
figurehead of it uh but this kind of
free speech
Tech censorship mainstream versus
independent free journalists I I can't
no one I don't I'm this is a broad
prediction but something that Lanes me
very very polarizing if not essential
election issue in the um in 2023. well
it is kind of interesting where you now
do have essentially if you're not
mainstream then then you're in this
other bucket of uh somehow controversial
uh very ways to start of the Free Press
yeah good for her our friend Barry and
it's exciting yeah and I think that
there's going to be
a lot of appetite for that sort of thing
is that what you're predicting yeah I'm
predicting whether the Free Press is I
mean I think there'll be a number of
them like even I don't even love these
guys but it's not called SEMA 4 is what
it's called was a number of I think it's
pronounced that before I thought
semaphore it's Dave Weigel and uh
BuzzFeed Ben
um and a few others have gone there's a
good Venture backing on on that project
too and they're a little more
establishment D Vibes
um but even those I I just think it's
it's dude I thought you were thinking
you're talking more youtubery than that
oh I agree my point is like even the
Main Street even your Dave Weigel's are
working for
new types of companies right like new a
little more independent they have more
freedom so that's like like that's not
the ones I think are gonna kick butt but
I think even like that's a Telltale sign
um I think it comes to a head I don't
know how
um but it's gonna be politicized because
these that is my point that the
mainstream media outlets and reporters
that have these big Twitter followings
and they work for the times in the post
and the journal or whatever it is
they're not going down without a fight
you know well yeah it's
it is going to be a theme of 2023 man
that's not bad all right I've got a
prediction that that we can then talk
about at some length I think Joe Biden
uh declares himself to be running for
reelection this year and I think that
takes place in
second quarter of 2023. now Joe Biden
has already taken a whole series of
steps essentially inoculating himself
from any challenges in the Democratic
primary the single biggest move was
putting South Carolina first and if you
remember South Carolina is the reason
why Joe won the nomination uh James
highburn saying go for Joe and then yeah
he talked about that on your podcast yet
like Iowa getting the boot from the
Democrats not really so so
um so you know could Joe be doing this
just uh to thank South Carolina
independent of his run sure
does it make a swell uh non-competitive
landscape for him if he decides to run
for reelection yes does Iowa has Iowa
earned the right
to be the first state again I think that
answer is overwhelmingly no right so so
the tough part here too Zach is that
Republicans are keeping Iowa so you're
seeing the yeah there's a red State yeah
and it's a red State now too true
um so so the two calendars are diverging
um for those of you who weren't up on
this the new Democratic order uh pending
some challenges and changes and whatnot
is South Carolina One Nevada and New
Hampshire the same day too uh Georgia
three
or four depending on why you want to
look at it
and then Michigan five and so that's the
the new Dem order pending New Hampshire
might try and jump the line they have a
state law saying they have to go first
so if they decide to go first then they
might get doc delegates or something or
other
um I I will suggest that if New
Hampshire does vote the same day as
Nevada
um then New Hampshire is going to get
somewhat overlooked because the matter
is just a bigger State and it's got more
uh more votes and more delegates and it
it does have more diverse populations
and some people will discount New
Hampshire if New Hampshire goes the same
day as Nevada New Hampshire probably
knows this and so that's why they're
going to try and go first but again in
this rural South Carolina's supposed to
go first so that's the new Democratic
calendar
and it's very good for Joe uh Joe is
feeling great given that he kept the
Senate and lost the house only by a few
seats even while most people expected a
republican wave uh so if you're Joe
Biden are you really going to step aside
at this point or you're going to look
around and be like look at all my Great
accomplishments uh why let there be this
massive scrum that no one knows who's
going to emerge from uh
uh how about I just run again and by all
accounts Jill Biden has warmed to this
idea
um they're going to talk it over the
holidays they're gonna dilly dally a
little bit but I think Joe declares
himself to be running and then I think
you're going to see every Democrat Under
the Sun say great decision Joe we're
behind you all the way
[Music]
a lot of questions unpack there so let's
do it do you
all right let's start with this one
let's start with just Joe himself do you
think it's because he knows Trump's
running and that he's the only one we've
been able to we being let's call it
Democrats have been able to
roster that can beat him who's proven to
beat him well that's been the rationale
for a long time which is I must defeat
Trump I'm the only one who can do it
um there's a strange Dynamic building
now though which is that uh
Trump actually is the most beatable
Republican nominee by the numbers right
now where uh where where Joe beats Trump
in a head-to-head by I think it's six or
seven points right now and and that
margins you know like misleading because
uh it just boils down to the swing
States and that's going to be a lot
closer there I mean you know just
because Joe runs up the score and
certain blue States doesn't matter but
uh but the the same poll had Joe losing
to DeSantis by several points so there
would be like an actual uh one of the
beauties of the two-party system is
you'd wind up with a lot of Democrats
rooting for Trump uh because he's uh
weaker I think you're gonna have poor
money and know him winning and then or
do something you know Elevate
um Trump again against the field you
know I think it's a
I think this is generic but like look if
you're team Dem you love Joe and
everything he does is great but if
you're you know you're independent or
you're moderate in some of these
capacities I think a vote for Joe
compared to Trump is usually the vote
for like uh you know it's essentially a
pro-democracy vote in many ways or just
you know uh or Pro like sanity in the
office and keep the institutions whole
right and you really everyone I think it
deep down knows they're voting for
Democratic Consultants deep down um
which is better than the chaos that
comes at Trump in their eyes
foreign
we all want to get a little bit more for
our money nowadays and one way to do
that is use expressvpn to access content
you can't get in the US let's say you're
a Netflix subscriber all it takes is one
tap of a button to change your locations
you can control which country Netflix
switches to I've used this when I wanted
to watch Vikings which is a great show
by the way because it wasn't available
in the US but it was in another country
there are now over 90 countries to
choose from and expressvpn works on
multiple streaming devices and services
not just Netflix so stop paying full
price for streaming services and only
getting access to a fraction of their
content get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com Yang don't forget to use
my links you can get three extra months
of expressvpn free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang
expressvpn.com Yang Netflix and other
streaming services anywhere in the world
foreign
[Music]
a lot of Democrats are comfortable with
Joe's age uh even if they like Joe uh
Independence very uncomfortable with
Joe's age like the average American's
like okay regardless of what I think
about this dude he'll be 82 at the end
of 2024. uh spry right yeah he's he's
like a non-medical miracle he's like you
know like uh
like uh I mean he's in a he's an above
average uh 80 year old you know
objectively a badass right like he looks
good yeah I mean you know I I I could
only because I'd fallen off bikes and
stuff he's you know I mean I can only
hope that I'm like you know like doing
it if I look like Joe Biden yeah yeah
exactly I'll take it I'll take it 10
seconds
that that said like I I don't expect to
be running for president two years later
I'm still working that hard shoot me
just one of the things that I've come
close to saying in some public setting
Zach is that if I'm still uh trying to
stay on stage past a certain age someone
just you know dragged me off immediately
and by the way you know Joe Biden when
he showed up at the rightful age of 29
when he was first running
um his entire thing was generational
change
um and so I mean sure the point is like
they're not fighting for anybody anymore
they're just loving the power and wealth
and success
you know it is unclear who his successor
is I mean and we all know that uh that
Kamala pulls yes that was the next
question who do you think Kamala Pete
who's gonna run well so if Joe declares
which I expect him to every
establishment Democrat will fall in line
and say Joe's our guy a lot of Americans
will be like well Joe was our guy but
he's going to be 82 at the end of 24 and
if I vote for him I have this very
uncomfortable feeling that I'm really
voting for his uh VP or his successor
which by the way added layer of
complexity I think will be Kamala again
because if he runs for re-election and
says hey it's not Kamala it's someone
else it's going to be a slap in the face
for certainly Kamala herself but then uh
you know like voters of color and uh
women of color and and so he's he's if
he runs again then he'll say hey it's me
and Kamala again and then a lot of
Americans would be like wait a minute
does this mean I'm actually voting for
president Harris because the odds of you
making it through your second term you
know middling at best uh and that and
there's going to be a real discomfort
with voting in an 82 year old would be
be by a really substantial margin easily
the oldest person uh ever to to be in
office but all of that said every
establishment Democrat will just Pile in
and say hey we're Team Joe all the way
um and then it's a question whether the
media would uh say what the average
American will be thinking which is hey
this guy's really old
um but this is what I expect to take
hold as the uh the process starts to
unfold uh this leaves me my third
prediction and then this will be good I
predict or that's my second prediction
sorry my I predict that Ron DeSantis
runs and wins in 2024 and it is an early
prediction so I'm probably getting hate
on Twitter but I think he runs and wins
that could very well be right so 2023
I've for a long time thought that Ron
running against Trump was something that
might or might not happen because it's a
very big bet and he could just sit out a
cycle and then we talked about it just
weeks ago and you're like doesn't make
any sense for him yeah and by the and by
the way by by all accounts also he has
like a legislative session until March
and so he's not going to make any
decisions before then but
I now think that it's more likely than
not that he does run and to your point
right now he's ahead of trump in the
polls the problem for Iran and maybe for
the country is that it's not going to be
Head to Head the Republican debates in
20
16
started in August
uh there were no Republican debates in
2020 because they just did away with the
primary uh for Trump's re-election by
the way something that most people do
not remember is that Trump had several
opponents for the Republican nomination
in 2020. uh William William weld Joe
Walsh
um some other people tried to run
against him so why are you like oh I
don't remember that I don't remember any
debates and the reason was that the RNC
just pulled the plug of the whole
process the the states just canceled
their building they said uh we we
essentially this is our King but yeah
yeah there there is no primary and so
then the the folks who are running
against him were like WTF
um I I said on CNN like a number of
weeks ago that the Democrats will
probably do the same [ __ ] uh in in this
cycle where if if Joe says hey I'm
running and then so what I said on air
was like look if Nina Turner and
Marianne Williamson run against Joe
there is no way that the Democrats are
going to make Joe debate them
five or six times it's just not gonna
have one or two that uh or I don't even
sure if there's one you know one thing I
can very easily see them saying is like
you know in order to have a debate or to
make this debate you have to be polling
at uh 20 I'll just move the goal post
and then if like you know Nina or
Marianne gets above 20 they'd be like we
meant 30. like whatever the number you
have it's like we meant 10 more
it's tough man I think that the
Democrats would just keep moving the
goal posts
um and the Republicans move the goal
post in 2020 and no one remember like
everyone there's no one cared
um so and the Democrats would be like
nothing to see here and do the same
thing especially because every
establishment Dem uh would be on team
Joe and then the only people that would
challenge him would be the Nina Turners
or Marion Williamson's who would be like
hey true democracy let the people speak
and the DNC would be like no no like you
know that that like uh The only voice we
can hear is is the president's
foreign
I have always been into my mattress what
do I mean when I was in my 20s logically
I thought you know if I'm going to spend
eight hours a day ideally sleeping I
should like the mattress I sleep on it's
probably going to pay for itself over
time in terms of health and energy
benefits technology has come a long long
way since my 20s and now you can use
Helix sleep to get a mattress that's
personalized to you just take their
sleep quiz at helixsleep.com they will
send you one of their 14 individual
types of mattresses to your home and you
can test it out up to 100 days risk-free
how are they so confident that you're
going to love their mattress maybe it's
because it's the number one mattress
picked by GQ wired and my kids you know
what I mean they just seek out the
mattress of the house Helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com Yang with Helix better
sleep starts now
foreign
so with that as the timeline let's say
the Republican
primary debates start same time this
cycle in August you're going to have
probably one Republican a month declare
throughout
2023 leading up to that for starting
into January baby Politico is going to
be lit so this month there's going to be
someone declare February another declare
like some of them are going to try and
hold off because they they're trying to
organize others want to go early so they
get some shine over under over under
I'll bet you this will be fun boba tea
bad that's fine when you raise the
stakes over under
15. does that feel right to set it okay
I take the under on that you take it
under on 15. yeah up
I'll take the over is that 50. this will
be fun boba tea bad that's fine so here
are some names for people to consider
that that that that I think are running
it's probably better at like 12 but no I
think you're I don't know let's try 15.
see what happens well well to in your
favor in the Democratic primary that I
was in uh the number was like 22
23.23 is going to go more but the
Republicans are a little there's Trump
and DeSantis in there they're better
about falling in line but who knows
we'll find out go ahead sir so here's
here who here's who I think runs uh in
some form or fashion Mike Pompeo yeah
Mike Pence
yeah Chris Christie yeah
Larry Hogan Tulsi gabbard Nikki Haley
huh
Francis Suarez
Ron DeSantis
yeah
Tim Scott
um
Donald Trump
that gets you to 10.
uh and so that that's that that's
approximately the field I think we're
looking at actually 15's good because
you know there's gonna be three like who
the hell are you right who's the guy in
Virginia that won
young kid the thing is Governor is a
good gig Governor's a good gig so I
don't know he's a new governor he's also
going to be one of the Next Generation
but Glenn young can apparently didn't
think he was going to run for governor
um and then he woke up one morning and
was like I'm running for governor and
then he ran for government and so he
just hasn't had that Epiphany where
president is concerned uh is what I
heard last time he just he says like
look if I just wake up one morning being
like I'm running for president that I'm
doing it he's like but I haven't woken
up with that feeling yet God he's Rich
enough to do it you have to be very rich
or have a really good idea to do or I
know you have to be very rich to do that
or do what you didn't start very early
so here's the Trump argument
uh he only got about 35 of the vote in
the early States in 16. so if he can
hold on to even 30 percent and the field
looks like what I just described
he probably wins because you'd have nine
candidates uh splitting maybe you know
someone would drop out before the voting
starts so you'd have like five
candidates splitting the non-trump vote
um so if Trump has 30 percent then
number two probably has 20 and then uh
you know Trump wins uh if you have a
hardcore 30 by the way something like
ranked Choice voting would fix all this
but whatever oh yeah but we don't forget
Solutions this is our reality so this is
DeSantis has 90 million left on hand
which is ridiculous because we raised 40
and change right like imagine we could
have done with 90. on day one
yeah so DeSantis does have some
um so you so you saw to Santa speak
right
yeah
yeah what were your impressions DeSantis
is uh
Jesus he he's compelling the scientist
yes is a very very talented politician
he's very very Town speaker he
understands and this is the thing that
that I will say about DeSantis love him
or hate him I don't want to make my own
opinion on him it's just he understands
the media today and he can do it in a
way that's very trumpian but not Trump
not an actual [ __ ] I mean you could
call him an actual ass if you know him
and other things but he's not
this unhinged
caricature of a human being that is
Donald Trump he's he's like it's all
that bottled into an effective
politician
um so
you know that yeah he's compelling he's
really compelling I haven't seen most of
these characters speak including
DeSantis so I I don't have enough I will
say he will like he's gonna get
scrutinized the way he never has been
before
um because right now it's just like
hated on by the press and does his stuff
in Florida he's a bit of a nerd
um he's like like he's not I think
people are the rights like what a badass
Just Dance it's like he's a nerd like
he's like a kind of a wonky type I mean
that like with some effect I'm not he's
a Harvard Law guy so he's kind of got
that wiring
um but he's very smart
um and he knows how to push back on the
media and like you know for those of you
that are liberal that listen to this
podcast like he bumped the minimum wage
up in Florida he put a lot of money to
work on climate change in the State of
Florida one of the most probably the
biggest states or biggest amount of
spending on climate change from a
government I'm a state government in the
United States so there are some things
he does that the moderate left or even
the far left would really like so
um that's where I look he's
if you're Trump you should be scared if
you're Biden you should be scared he's
an effective politician that's why he's
my prediction I think he's really
talented
are they like it and not ignore policy
you know and a lot of people hate him
and I don't mean to piss people he's got
the resources he's got uh the name ID
um I think it was one on one him versus
Trump he wins
um you know the the one of his problems
is that uh Chris Christie and Larry
Hogan I believe were both running and
they're both uh Governors who have track
records that they can point I mean much
more Larry Hogan Larry Hogan was a very
very popular governor of a blue State uh
Maryland
um and I I have met with Larry Hogan
he's he's uh very talented and uh smart
and genuine and winning
um Chris Christie was actually a much
more talented speaker than you'd imagine
um like having watched him work a crowd
um guys for lunch right it's just I
don't think he'll eat the santis I don't
know if he can defeat Haley either
because it's the strong Haley's very
very talented by all accounts so you're
going to have a bunch of people in this
race uh and Trump's law launch has been
a dud
and you know the single biggest problem
for Trump that I felt immediately
um was that running for president for
real requires a lot of energy
um and do you think that Trump will have
the energy to run around for 14 months
until the voting starts uh the early
answer is are he does not seem to uh and
and so uh you know I think it's one
reason why some people are trying to
time their launch in a particular way
because you need to Peak in February of
24
um when for them their voting starts in
Iowa so to recap a little bit uh you
have in my opinion Joe Biden on one side
and then you're going to have this uh
relatively robust Republican field on
the other uh and Zach thinks that
DeSantis emerges
um I think that right now you'd have to
put DeSantis as a favorite
it's interesting because
it's like the mainstream media woke up
and they realized if we just don't talk
about him
things are great uh you know the only if
you look up what if you Google Donald
Trump or if you see Donald Trump in the
news now the only thing really tied to
it is he's either getting sued by
somebody or he's losing in the polls
um now Twitter
is a factor there because the reporters
are always on Twitter and they used to
just write about his tweets and so that
is a thing
um Barry Weiss just released for those
of you maybe not on Twitter Elon has
like released
basically the inner workings of Twitter
during
uh you know the 2020 election
essentially and and some other times I
mean specifically the decision to ban
Trump
it's wild Barry Weiss has it and they
have to release it on Twitter but Barry
Weiss is thread on uh what they did to
the platform Trump from from the
platform or from Twitter is crazy but I
can't imagine like having worked at a
big company at UBS before I can't
imagine
inner chats being aired out like dirty
laundry to the world dude I mean
seriously but yeah or text messages I
mean we all do yeah NDM uh just the most
random rancid [ __ ] and then imagine them
being put out for public consumption and
be like this is where are like what they
were thinking it's like oh my gosh I
don't love that I do agree I understand
it because they made I mean they
de-platform the leader of the Free World
at the time or the you know I guess he
had lost but still um and I don't agree
with that I mean if you look
um they've kept a lot of awful people on
their platform for the record I think
that's one of the big ones people don't
always realize and Barry outlines it
really well
um
so it is you're so you're saying if
Trump comes back on Twitter it might
help change the dynamic it certainly
would help change the the media the
mainstream it is funny reflecting upon
how dominant he was
um coming up in 2016 and then really
through his loss in 2020
um now he's not on Twitter meaningfully
uh you know even though he's been re uh
re I guess he has been he's welcome back
now right um oh yeah he could tweet but
he hasn't he could because his financial
fortunes are tied to propping up this
truth social and this is this is kind of
my point my my first prediction is like
I think if Trump has success uh in the
primary and and as a candidate here it
will make this mainstream versus
Outsider uh particularly in the media
like front and center in this race if
like he can rally supporters without
anyone in mainstream media including the
right really is not really covering that
much
um and no Twitter No anything
we're in a new world you know
um I don't think it's I don't think it's
gonna be possible but I get wrong some
other predictions for 2023 and I'm gonna
have some fun they're going to be a
little bit rapid fire I think the Third
Way in American politics uh the this uh
new pathway actually becomes uh stronger
and clearer uh to more and more people
and I think that the presidential field
actually helps because if I'm right and
Joe runs
um they're going to be a lot of people
who aren't that pumped about either Joe
or us whoever they think is going to
emerge from the Republican field you
know if it was Trump which is still a
possibility by the way no 50 58 of
Americans don't want either of those
choices uh and and so you'd have the
average American just looking around
being like okay what are my other
choices I think that that's going to be
something that uh that becomes a thing
the forward party uh here's a prediction
will get recognition
um in 20 plus States in 2020. I'm very
excited
yeah that's exciting so we'll be
building out the the new approach to
American politics uh please do check it
out at fordparty.com it's a very
self-serving prediction but what can I
say also to put you a little bit on the
spot but my I predict that Zack here
launches a company that's very exciting
and we'll have to uh to talk to him
about this exciting company
and uh I predict that I will have a new
book project come out sometime in 2023
it's not going to be until the fall
um but I I did something fun with a
collaborator
um that we're hoping to get out into the
world uh toward the end of this year I
know these are like predictions that I
know are true so sorry about that
everyone yeah you know these are teasers
brother you are just teasing
cool [ __ ] you're working on which is I
think fine but you're you know you can't
be wrong on stuff like this
I predict Zach gets married I predict I
stay married get married my children get
one year older
I have I have one more prediction it's a
little out there which is a take is that
there's been plenty of web 3 companies
right now but I don't think web3 is
mainstream at all I think it's mainly
around cryptocurrencies and exchanges my
prediction is that
a mainstream web3
a unicorn starts to take off in 2023
where
folks like my mother and my casual
friends who don't really know what
ethereum is ETC start to use web3 I
think this is the year
um where like the equivalent of a
Facebook
for web3 I'm not saying it's a social
media company but something where it's
widely used starts to get legs I don't
have to you know have to have Facebook
growth but it starts to really take off
well the the big problem with web3 has
been that the primary use has been
Financial speculation which is not great
yeah
um so I I advise a company called pool
that is using web3 to give people
ownership of their own data and it's
going to kick off in Earnest in 2023 in
the EU because the EU has rules that uh
that kick in which give you the right to
to
have custodianship of your own data and
a point uh surrogate or proxy to
negotiate for you or to to take care of
your data so pool is enabling an
infrastructure where you can make those
determinations and then create data
unions uh and the hope is that they can
bring it over to the U.S the EU just has
these rules that are in place there's
not a real National approach to it in
the U.S because of our Oso enlightened
government that doesn't know what the
[ __ ] it's doing and anything uh data
related or technology so they just let
the companies do whatever the hell they
want
um but that's an example of an
application where it doesn't you don't
need to even understand web3 necessarily
you can just be like hey do you want
um do you want your own data do you want
it to go with you wherever you go do you
want some money for it and then people
be like yes
um so the folks in the EU will be able
to do that that's not going to you know
I mean most people the the US won't uh
care until it's here obviously but but
that's an example of something that
could happen
um uh in in the months to come I think
it's close
um there's a lot of and the driver of
this prediction is that it's a recession
and that and Venture money has dried up
I mean there's a lot of it out there but
it's not going to you're not seeing the
ridiculous valuations we were seeing you
know
2020 and 2019 2021 so I think really
good companies start when
um times are tight so that's uh I think
and I think a lot of resources have gone
into web three so I think you'll start
to see some traction there that's my big
I don't know that's a big take but maybe
it is well you know I hope you're right
man again because Financial speculation
is now what these tools optimally could
be used for I mean it's a side of the
times that like that's the first use
that everyone got excited about here's a
question I have for you Andrew
um let's say it's
DeSantis
you can pick Haley you can pick any of
them but like a non-trump versus Biden
what's the messaging what do you think
the left dies on what do you think the
right dies on like the hills that they
die on and like because that's going to
be the central issue of the next
probably more 2024 but it's going to
start heating up in 2023 well you know
it's funny because I said it before I
think that
um Biden's foil is Trump in the sense
that like you know hey I'm Biden uh help
you make things normal again and then if
you put Biden up against uh DeSantis or
Haley uh or Scott or any of these other
characters then mine's just gonna seem
really old and uh and and that's not a
great contrast so you're going to see a
total demonization of whoever Joe's
opponents are if it's DeSantis you're
gonna have like the the mainstream
message police anti-woke movement uh
from the right in addition to I think
you're gonna see a lot of Reagan
messaging that's like smaller government
lower taxes tough on crime
um because those things are all like the
by Administration has spent a lot of
money crime is up government is big uh
the economy is not great so I think
that's where you go on the left I'm not
sure it'll be somewhat of the keep this
soul of America going
uh trust us because the right is evil I
think is probably what that's what I'm
saying it's just going to become very
oppositional Last Prediction I have is
uh in 2023 Buffalo Bills become Super
Bowl champions the Buffalo Bills win the
Super Bowl we're gonna go to Glendale
Arizona we're gonna be probably the
Philadelphia Eagles and raise the
Lombardi for the first time Buffalo
history
I seem amazing I'm gonna be there I'll
be crying grown man crying like baby and
then I might get a tattoo we're not sure
Carly my fiance tracks my blood pressure
a bit when I watch a Bills game and it
it's bikes it's not good it's not good
enough she's like there's like a monitor
but she can just tell that I'm well you
know it's gonna Spike when they win the
Super Bowl too man so uh good luck to
you you have the joy that one moment is
I'm gonna keep going with this uh okay
right now I I I'd have to say the
Celtics win the NBA title Celtics look
good man they're mad they're mad you
know they lost the finals they're bad
they're young they're athletic they're
Scrappy
um I think they can win the East I think
they can uh win the whole thing I mean
in the West geez man I mean the Warriors
seem vulnerable but then they came out
of nowhere and wanted last year
um I don't know what's going on in the
west there's stuff to go against the
Warriors you know Celtics warriors uh I
don't know enough about the NBA to make
smart takes but uh the Celtics do look
good here's a big prediction for 2024
at least one more U.S senator declares
their independence from the two major
parties joining Kirsten Cinema in doing
so who's it gonna be here are two very
very big possibilities Joe manchin the
Manch recently said no guarantee he
stays a Democrat up for re-election in
2024 in West Virginia which is a state
that Trump won by 38 points so how
popular is it to be a democrat in West
Virginia not very uh so you could see
Joe manchin join Kirsten Cinema in being
an independent who else might become an
independent Lisa murkowski out of Alaska
doesn't have to face re-election for six
years might this might have been her
last race uh and if she's an independent
she gets to do what she wants gets to be
incredibly influential oh by the way
they got rid of party primaries in
Alaska and she just fended off a trump
endorsed Challenger uh and most of the
people who voted for her I'm gonna say
were probably Independents or moderates
anyway including some Democrats she and
Mary paltola the Democrat cross endorsed
each other so if you're Lisa murkowski
do you really owe the Republican Party a
whole heck of a lot at this point no so
you're going to see yet another
independent U.S senator and then if you
do the math on that depending upon who
it is you could wind up with those
independent Senators being vital to get
anything done in the Senate any uh
approvals appointments uh certainly laws
though
um you know like though I'm hesitating
on that because
um uh another prediction for 2024 you're
going to see a real mess in the House of
Representatives in terms of their
ability to pass legislation you have a
republican majority of five seats but
this Republican majority does not get
along at all like you have folks like
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
over on the side just jumping up and
down and then you have some folks who
are a lot more reasonable than that so
they're going to have a really hard time
getting any legislation across the
finish line and it's going to be up to
the Democrats whether they want to bail
them out and get them some votes on
various things
um it's going to be it's not not going
to be a good legislative environment and
the Republicans aren't really into
passing [ __ ] anyway
um so you know yeah so so you're going
to see some very very strange Dynamics
coming out but not a whole lot of
legislation uh because
um the the polarization unfortunately is
going to get the better of it three
independent Senators that's great and
you know what that means is that means
because it's going to be split and
there's going to be a fragmented power
you'll probably have 10 like wishy-washy
Senators if you will whether it's you
know you're gonna you're gonna wind up
with by the way there's actually some
scuttlebutt too like I think there are
some folks trying to work on some kind
of uh fulcrum in the Senate that extends
to both independent caucus maybe it's
the forward caucus who knows yeah maybe
who knows but you know there might be a
couple of card carrying Independents in
there gonna be wild you're gonna be a
great year yes happy 2023 everyone may
it be the best year yet you know there's
a lot of like blah blah blah in the
world but the most important thing is
that you approach it with confidence and
enthusiasm and optimism just take care
of yourself accomplish your goals [ __ ]
the noise [ __ ] the stuff that's out
there as as long as you're taking care
of your family your business uh your
loved ones it's all to the good uh and
then we're just gonna build build build
and then people who are on the outside
being like oh what are you doing over
there are you you know Beaver
conscientious Builders or whatever and
then they come back and guess what
Hoover Dam
uh love each other y'all we love you
guys have a great 2023. Happy New Year
everybody
thank you